[Musica]
chi è
un regalo per me è sì sì ok arrivo
subito
[Musica]
grazie ma tu chi sei
ebbene
grazie
ciao
fitness world
record
[Musica]
idea
verità che fai ciao vitale guarda mi
hanno regalato il libro dei guinness dei
primati e ho avuto un'idea proviamo a
tentare un record un record
fammi pensare
mangiare più panini di 30 secondi sì sì
sono pronto a farlo ma insomma deve
sempre pensare a mangiare guarda ci sono
tantissimi record adesso in più basta
unghie più lunghe al mondo
quanto sono lunghe salti della corda con
i capelli piedi più grandi al mondo
guarda c'è anche la donna più bassa fino
all'uomo più alto al mondo ed è alto due
metri e 51 tutto molto interessante ma
dove sono i record del cibo e va bene
origine
gastronomia ecco allora abbiamo le prime
uova di pasqua nel
1873 i primi pop corn risalgono a 6.700
anni fa è il primo zucchero filato e
aspetta però che non puoi battere questi
record mi dispiace perché questo il
primo zucchero filato il primo pop corn
quindi dobbiamo cercare la sezione
record cibo mangiato remoto di cibi che
ci sono e peperoncino purè di patate
black di mais al formaggio più lungo hai
detto
fini si cucini ecco li vedi deve dire
che questo è il record perfetto per te
non so non ho mai provato a mangiare un
peperoncino intero così sarà troppo
piccante no no no non preoccupati anzi
la cosa più bella è che abbiamo un sacco
di peperoncini in giardino quindi vado
subito a prenderli to preparati con
piatto fazzoletti proveremo a battere
questo record va bene ok l'importante è
che si mangi ma mi preparo subito adesso
basta in questo nuovo video dovremmo dei
record del ricordo sarà super divertente
a chi come stiamo parlando di record
provate voi a lasciare o mi piace entro
tre sono lì pronti
[Applauso]
siete riusciti alla sera mi piace entro
tre secondi e ora iniziamo subito con il
record dei peperoncini
siamo i giardino guardate quanti
peperoncini abbiamo qua
che carini sono rossissimi chi seguito
sono ficcante non vedo l'ora di vedere
la faccia di vitale quando li manderà
e poi abbiamo anche questi che sono tono
di chi sono più piccanti qui
è un peperoncino verde quanto store o
piccante questo beh direi che abbiamo un
bel po di peperoncini adesso andiamo
portarle a milano sei pronto per questa
sfida
prontissimo hai molta fame è un pochino
sia ti ho portato vari varietà di
peperoncini peperoncino verde poi però
il cile giallo per perugino
e
peperoncino allora da quale peperoncino
vuoi iniziare
allora io pensavo di iniziare con quello
verde che sembra quello meno piccante
poi magari passare al giallo l'arancione
forse lo lascerei per ultimo non lo so
perché ma mi ispira poca fiducia secondo
me è piccantissimo e poi invece abbiamo
questi tre piccolini rossi che però il
ciro verde
è buono unificante poco poco
è un pochettino ficcante
percorre sopportabile diciamo quando
imbeccato da una 10 1 la piccantezza
difende anche dal colore infatti guarda
quello verde è il meno piccante poi si
sale fino al giallo un po più piccante
poi arancione ancora più piccante poi il
rosa il più piccante di tutti sei pronto
a mandare il prossimo peroncino giallo
ok passiamo di livello giallo
non sono sicuro se andare con un morso
diretto e
coraggioso ci provo vai
meglio vediamo un pezzettino
gigante
[Risate]
cosa hanno capito l'importanza
questo maggior livello secondo me è ok
secondo me questo è il piccante di tutti
io non ho il coraggio di morderlo però
questo dettaglio solo un pezzettino
giu sono l'odore piccante
[Musica]
[Risate]
notificate dalla 10 9 e mezzo
ultimo sbrighiamoci ultimo
rosso pronti per la sfida finale
peperoncino rosso piccante
io questo però non riesco borderline a
picco
[Musica]
sono pronto ad ogni tempo nessuno
castro di più
o progetto fuoco sei stato bravissimo ma
ora controlliamo subito se abbiamo
battuto il record qua c'è scritto il
tempo più veloce per mangiare 50
peperoncini è stato di soli 68 secondi
cosa ma io non ho mangiato solo un
pezzettino pochi secondi non lo so è che
non abbiamo battuto il record è stato
super divertente ho un'altra idea però
siccome noi non riusciamo a batterie
core potremo provare questi record di
canino
un cane un gatto sul monopattino
che vernice andrebbero sono monopattino
insieme
e mi sa che merita non andrebbe suo
monopattino perché è un po pigro ne
guarda questo il cane con le orecchie
più lunghe al mondo dobbiamo misurare le
orecchie di merlino o che evitiamo che
la misurazione delle orecchie orecchia
lino 13 cm capita rimangono piegate le
orecchie di berlinesi orecchio destro di
berlino 13 cm
[Risate]
proviamo a misura nella testa di marlena
ben 22 cm di testa mai formi un testo
nei grandi per col nasone lungo lungo si
crediamo saver 6 k berlino vi ha dato un
bacino hai detto 13 cm eh sì vorrei che
ora di 13 sti qua dice che il carico le
orecchie più lunghe e una femmina di
nome lui e le sue orecchie misurano 34
cm ciascuna
34 aspetta però c'è un altro record
superman
altri oggetti consecutivi afferrati al
volo il bravo ad afferrare le cose al
volo soprattutto se si tratta di cibo
come vitale
con meno un buon berlino con berlino
come con berlino anch'io sono capace a
prendere il cibo al volo
mezzo ai locali grotti per la challenge
e berlino e posizione anche vitale e
devo avviare il timer e poi dobbiamo
tenere il conto di
quante cose appello berlino
padre
[Musica]
mario masi 6 bryan 1 bravo
bravo
bravissimo
ovest accaduto quindi meno 1 lasciando
primo crono bravo fatto manca e
quanti premietti avrà presto berlino in
un minuto
contiamo berlino ha preso al volo 9
premietti ma qua c'è scritto che sasha
ha afferrato 10 snack il fila lanciati
da 3 metri e poi il primo febbraio ha
afferrato dal volo dieci oggetti in
9,69 secondi e berlino già questo un
minuto
si è visto berlino quella questo cane
questo benedetto xvi non mi sa che ci fu
l'angolo che più goloso di tempo e che
c'erano come col bravissimo berlina se
vuoi provare qualche record anche tu hai
visto più bel gatto presto tornerà visto
che balcani olona gigante è stato super
divertente tentare questi record anche
se non ti voglio ft a superarli è stato
divertentissimo il libro guinness world
record 2022 disponibile ed è un'ottima
idea regalo qui se siete indecisi sul
regalo di natale se dovete fare qualche
regalo qualche vostro amico parete vi
consiglio il libro guinness world record
2022 scriveteci nei commenti anche
berlino concordo lo ha detto con la sua
zampa che cosa vuoi vuoi vedere anche il
libro puoi vedere altri cani uniti per i
chirurghi steve e vediamo qua damerino
questo è un panno quale fatto il vostro
momento preferito di questo video per me
l'italia che fa del peperoncino la saga
bel mi piace ora vi lasciamo fa quattro
cartellini su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite
[Musica]